[Música]
i
nosotros salimos campeón como es el fin
de semana pero no vinimos a hablar de
eso venimos a hablar de lo que puede ser
posible y lo que no muchos dicen y que
levantaron la mano que son efectos
especiales
nosotros logramos esto con manos propias
con trabajo con esfuerzo
empezamos con esto
con un pequeño auto
cualquiera diría que nunca se iba a
poder convertir en eso
todo comenzó una tarde de agosto hace
más de un año cuando el intendente de
nuestro municipio de campo grande
asistió a nuestra institución la epet
número 25 con la idea de hacer algo
innovador algo creativo que pueda
mezclar la imaginación la creatividad
con los cálculos y el trabajo
de todos los proyectos que había
elegimos él
el transformers que era el más llamativo
el que nos planteaba más desafíos
y comenzamos trabajando varios chicos de
diferentes edades
incluso tenemos chicos que están ahora
viendo porque no podemos estar todos
sino que somos juan y yo
pero
comenzamos
el director de nuestra institución
gestionó con varios profesores para que
puedan traer un vehículo desde la
municipalidad que estaba tirada en la
chatarra después de un accidente
bueno
todo comenzó con la llegada del robot a
nuestra institución también lo que se
hizo fue primero que nada limpiaron
porque estaba lleno de barro por el
tiempo en desuso
se empezó a hacer lo que es
el corte en la parte delantera se sacó
lo que es el guardabarro la caja al
motor
todo lo que pueden ver
también se hizo una modificaciones en el
chasis porque como todos sabemos que
está auto no está para
para desarmarse
también se hizo
unos cambios que permite que el auto
cuando se eleva que no se toquen ni una
pieza lo que es la parte del brazo
no se toque con la
parte donde va el motor del auto
directamente lo que hace es se quiebra
en esta foto en la que puso mi compañero
podemos apreciar lo que es el esqueleto
le vemos raro de la forma pero es
bastante sencilla
bueno comenzamos trabajando con cortando
hierros haciendo los cálculos pero no
podíamos trabajar abriendo y cerrando el
vehículo sino que fue un trabajo donde
no podíamos volver atrás no nos podíamos
equivocar y empezamos trabajando de esta
forma
primero limpiando el vehículo luego
cortando piezas que nos servían luego lo
abrimos y le dimos la forma
luego
llegamos a empezar a cubrirlo
a que empieza a tomar forma de a poquito
día tras día tuvimos un lapso de un mes
justo era el lanzamiento de la escuela
de robótica en su programa robótico
workshop educativo para el nivel inicial
para las maestras de primaria
y de a poquito fuimos logrando esto
el vehículo como lo ven así y así
está creado básicamente con estructuras
de hierro muy uniformes no se cae no se
rompe y todo fue gracias al trabajo de
los profesores y alumnos
pero la parte más interesante es cómo
logramos hacer que se levante
tuvimos que ese fue nuestro mayor
desafío cómo hacer que se levante se
cierre se transforme
cuando tuvimos que usar el motor usamos
motores de 220
no levantaba porque era muy pesado y
empezamos a crear locos no sabíamos cómo
resolverlo
entonces llegó un punto en donde ya
estábamos muy estresados
y nos dijimos paramos acá
vamos a agarrar y pensar bien que vamos
a hacer en el auto ahí fue cuando
decidimos hacer un sistema de reducción
y que se pueda manipular utilizando lo
que es sistema de poleas que lo que van
en una técnica sabrán muy bien lo que es
eso
nosotros valoramos mucho
el emprendimiento la enseñanza muchas
veces
un chico de una escuela normal diría yo
porque para nosotros no somos normales
estamos arreglados
las enseñanzas la tecnicatura todo lo
que vamos aprendiendo se desarrolló haga
cálculos de poleas cálculos de fuerza
todos mecanismos máquina
todos los elementos que podríamos usar
fue el desarrollo de ese mes
literalmente quedamos locos y si también
algo que aprendimos que creo yo que
ninguna técnica te enseña es hacer chapa
y pintura a un auto
eso es algo muy muy llamativo
como dijo mi compañero tuvo un accidente
de auto tenía muchas abolladuras y lo
que se hizo fue arreglarla para dejarle
lo mejor posible
bueno nuestro proyecto el año pasado fue
considerado como el misionero del año
también
viajamos a todas las provincias perdonó
a todas las provincias a todas partes de
las provincias mostrando el trabajo lo
que es posible con esfuerzo tratando de
motivar a chicos que se unan a nosotros
que por ahí la gente ignorante dice no
no se puede como vimos en el vídeo
inicial todos posibles chicos
todo le agradecemos mucho también a
todos nuestros profesores alumnos que
estuvieron acompañándonos a todos
nosotros
vale la pena el esfuerzo así que a todos
chicos que están interesados en hacer un
proyecto loco porque esto es un proyecto
muy loco estaría
muy lindo que se acerca a sus profesores
le digan sus ideas sus proyectos y los
profesor están ahí lo van a escuchar
muchas gracias muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
no